Some people are panicking because I
showed the email yesterday
[clears throat] of the receipts I have
where the situation that they're
accusing me with my ex-wife and I and me
supposedly being a wife beater and
people are like panicking saying, "Oh,
you showed the email where I lashed
out." No, brethren, that was deliberate.
So, this poor brother was panicking. You
mods, that was deliberate. Take it easy.
I'm telling you, I have
the receipts. I have the emails for the
full situation if I have to mention it.
So, I know you guys are concerned. Let
me explain one more one more thing. I've
never lied to anyone and I'm not going
to lie to you. I've been very honest
with you guys. Sorry, I got bit. I don't
know if I got bit. So,
for the record, just to say cuz this
poor brother was panicking for me there.
For the record, just let you know, I
deliberately show that email because I
have the receipts. Sorry, man. See this
right here? I got bit. Okay, so you guys
panicking. No, I said I have the
receipts. I have the email in case I
need to give the full story. So now, for
your benefit, let me explain. You ready?
I'm going to explain it. But I want to
wait for Sunday if they're that dirty
and they mention it so that I can then
have to now bring additional details.
Sorry. Yeah. So, sorry for the drama.
This is just the drama, right? Yeah,
man. No, this was in my state. I got
bit. So, yesterday I showed that I have
receipts and they saw the email and then
they saw me saying that I lashed out at
my wife. Yeah, lashed out. But there's a
context. It's not
I'm a white beater. I'm not a white
beater. I just want to be clear. I
deliberately showed that. I wasn't
hiding it.
So, I guess you guys didn't understand.
I deliberately showed to show you the
facts of the situation. Now, sorry guys.
I know you don't want to hear the drama.
I apologize, okay? I don't want to bore
you with my problems, but just for the
record, the brothers listening, I wanted
to show the email to have the receipts.
Now, do you guys want me to talk about
it real in brief? Sorry about that.
Damn. You guys want to mention it in
brief?
Yeah,
I can, but I want to wait to see what
they're going to do. And eventually I
will then do full disclosure receipts
and everything. Okay,
brethren,
when they tell you I'm a white beater,
that's a false. That's a lie. That did
not happen. That did not happen. I'm not
a white beater. Even my ex-wife can
testify.
Now, I'm going to wait for them to
unleash
whatever they're going to unleash on
Sunday. And I got emails. David Wood's
going to be in the emails and then other
things that I'm going to bring up
against David Wood. If he stoops that
low to show that he's a low life,
what happened is again, see, I want to
just share this with you guys because
if I share it, people are going to think
that I'm justifying
or
what's the word I'm looking for?
Deflecting. Okay,
there are
dozens of eyewitnesses that are still
available. You can reach out to them and
ask them. Even the elders of the church
that I was involved, right?
Even my ex-wife brother, people are
still friends with me.
This accusation of these Muslims that
look to my court file said that I'm a
white beater or now that apostate
prophet has chimed in with Anthony
Rogers saying white beater. That is a
lie. I'm not a white beater. So just I
will give you the details if you want
them because I've never lied to any of
you. But I have to be careful what I say
because right now
my daughters are not kids anymore. So
now my daughters are going to be now
cons constantly exposed to the situation
with their mother and I and to the
online bickering. So I pray God protects
them. I don't care what anyone thinks of
me.
I don't care what anyone thinks of me.
I'm letting you know what matters is
that Jesus is not displeased with me.
That Jesus is not disgusted with me.
That Jesus does not hand me over and has
pity on me and forgives me and my
daughters. That's all that matters to me
on earth. I want to glorify Jesus Christ
till I die and take care of my daughters
and that's it. Whether people like me,
whether people don't want to support me,
that's between you and the Lord. That's
your conviction.
That is your conviction. And if you feel
convicted that you don't want to support
me, follow your conviction. Follow the
Lord Jesus Christ. Sorry guys, it's
killing me. [snorts] Okay? I've never
lied and I will not lie to you. This
incident about me being a white beater,
that's not what happened.
So, I have to be careful because I don't
want to demonize my ex-wife
any worse than she's already demonized
herself. I have to be careful. The Lord
is my witness and I have eyewitnesses
who are still my friends. In fact,
several of them are going to be with me
for PBD.
They're going to be with me. They're
witnesses to this. They're all witnesses
to this. Thank you, Leon. Even Albi
said, "If you want me to come to
testify, will many witnesses will tell
you for 10 years I lived." So, I have to
be careful. I'm going to say this
because people say, "Oh, look, look at
you." Right?
You're trying to justify. No, there's no
justification. I'm a sinner. I've never
proved otherwise. For 10 years, I would
get verbally abused and physically hit.
Physically hit. That's the fact. God is
my witness. Witnesses, no one can deny
that. There was an occasion where we're
in the car and I even tell you was on
Thanksgiving. I remember 2014.
Something happened between my ex-wife
and her brother. They got into an
argument. Days leading up to
Thanksgiving, it wasn't going good for
us because the arguments and the
shouting escalated and her physical
hitting me escalated. The Lord is my
witness. What I'm going to tell you
this, guys, because I owe it to you. I'm
going to tell you prior to that event,
my ex-wife
threw a spoon the back of my head, my
head open, and I started on my white
shirt in front of my young daughters.
So, I played it off because my daughters
were there. The day after that, she
started pounding me, punching me. I
grabbed her nams and she started biting
me. She left bruises on my arms. the
Lord is listening if I'm lying to you
guys. So, you can do with it what you
want.
It then escalated that on Thanksgiving
because I remember because it was
November 27. It was it was Thanksgiving.
It was Bruce Lee's birthday. Went to my
in-law. Her and her brother got into an
argument. She blamed me for it. She was
driving. We're in the car. So, I'm going
to just tell you in the car. I used to
have a beard. I even have the license.
She starts screaming to high heaven.
Driving, my kids in the back, crying,
yanking my beard, punching me in the
chest. I jump out of the car and I say,
"Help." That's what I used to do, by the
way. When she would scream, I'd open the
door and scream for help. So then what
happens? I get in the car. She starts
find yanks. When she yanked from the
pain and [clears throat] anger, I
reacted. I hit her back.
Hit her back from the passenger side.
That's what happened. Now, my knuckle
hit her eye and it got swollen. That's
what happened. So, guess what she did?
She started taking pictures because that
was the moment she was waiting for. Sent
it to people to try to destroy my
ministry. That's what happened. I'm not
a white beater. I've never hit a woman.
even that even though
there is no justification
but when you have someone who is a
sinner who's imperfect who has his own
issues you can condemn me if you want
you can stop I understand perfectly but
that's what happened and the only people
understand what I've been through are
those who've had to live with abusive
spouses that's what happened so this
about white beating that's a lie I'm not
a white Peter. She has testified with
her own mouth.
He's never been violent before. I don't
feel threatened by him. Even afterwards,
he's never been threat violent and I
don't feel threatened by She said that
in front of the court when she served me
divorce papers in 2017.
This is the honest to God truth.
But they keep using it over my head to
try to use that to destroy the ministry.
And God doesn't need me, guys. God's God
doesn't need me.
God doesn't need me. So if the Lord
wants to shut me down, you won't lose
anything, brethren. You don't need me.
You won't lose anything. This is what
happened.
You understand this? What happened?
David Wood is a witness to this. And I
have the emails. This is why David Wood
and them never stopped doing ministry
with me.
Never stopped doing ministry with me.
This is why my church did not throw me
out.
They asked us to seek marriage
counseling. That didn't work either.
None of that. It wouldn't work. So, I
understand if you guys hate me for it
and want to stop. I believe me, you
follow your conviction. And I'm going to
say it again. You do not need me. But
the Lord is my witness. They're lying to
you when it says that I'm a white beard.
That is a lie from the pit of hell. So I
deliberately show the email because
these guys think they're scaring me. You
know who flees? The wicked. But the
righteous are bold as lions. And you
know the only people. Yeah. And I have
the emails. I have them saved. I'll show
it to you guys. I'll show it to you.
Brother, I have the emails. Scotch. I
swear. Here. Let me show it to you so
you guys don't think I'm lying. You
know, understands
someone who's been in abusive relation
with a man beating a woman or a woman.
There are women who beat their husbands.
This is a fact before the Lord. And God
will damn me to hell if I'm lying. So,
how low and scum are these bastards to
try to use that to try to discredit me?
So, now I told you, but I wanted to
wait. I swear to you, it wasn't my
intention to bring it up. I wanted to,
but because this brother panicked, he
go, "Oh, they saw it." I want you to see
the email. So I apologize to you guys.
This is why God saved me from that
Jezebel and removed me from the state.
Because brethren, if I was still in the
state, this woman would have drove me to
or I would have been in jail.
This woman, in fact, Alb is listening.
Albby, when I went to Chicago to visit
my family,
she instigated a situation with her
husband to try to beat up Albi. Thank
God my friend Ali controlled himself
from beating him to oblivion front of my
daughters. She has no fear of the Lord.
Ali is my witness. That's why I said,
"Anytime you want, I'll come up and
testify. Anytime you want. That's why I
stopped going to Chicago, people. I
stopped going to Chicago."
No. Obviously, he's going to mention it.
You know why solution? How does apostate
prophet know when he says, "Oh, you're
not going to beat me like you beat
women." I stop going to Chicago for that
reason.
I don't go back because I cannot risk
going to a state and she causes drama
and then the police get involved. She
instigated this guy, this adulterous man
that she's married to. She instigated
where he came out acting brave trying to
punk Albi. And God blessed Albi to
control himself cuz Albi did not want to
react and hit him and knock him out in
front of my daughters. But that's the
kind of scene she caused.
Okay. That's why I don't visit. Why do
you think my daughters come and visit
me? I can't, brethren. And I have emails
telling David Wood, David Wood, for
years. I told you I have it. Emails,
document. I got receipts. I'm not afraid
of these guys. these punks come because
that's all they can do is discredit me
but they can't refute me. They can't.
What does that tell you that they're
making about an issue that happened in
2014? In the email I'd say, David, you
know, for years I told you this woman
keeps hitting me. I have the email. You
were witness when I said I know she
keeps hitting me. I don't know what to
do. I'm afraid that one day she's going
to hit and I'm going to snap. I'm human.
I have the emails.
See, emails don't lie. Receipts don't
lie. And to prove to you that he knows
I'm right, why did he keep doing
ministry with me?
Can you explain why Anthony Rogers,
why David Wood, they all would still do
ministry with me, platform me, and do
shows with me? See, their hatred of me
or their alienation me has nothing to do
with this situation. Is because I'm not
an ass kisser.
I'm not an asskisser. That's what they
can't stand. I'm not going to kiss their
ass
here. Let me show you the email so you
guys don't know I'm lying. So, I'm
sorry. I didn't wasn't going to bring it
up, but my poor brother William who
loves me and cares for me. He's like,
"Brother, they saw email." I go, "I did
it deliberately because I don't want
people to think I'm lying." I'm not
lying to you. I have not lied to you
guys. Now, you want to condemn me, it's
your choice. I deserve hell. But if you
understand that even those who try the
hardest to serve the Lord struggle with
the flesh and I married a Jezebel to my
shame. But I can't regret it, brethren.
You know why I can't regret it? The
greatest thing that came out of my
marriage is my daughters. I will never
ever regret never ever regret marrying
her because of these two angels. If the
Lord were to tell me, the Lord were to
tell me, guys, if the Lord were to tell
me, I'll go back in time, and you don't
have to marry Michelle.
I would ask the Lord, but would you
still give me my two daughters? He says,
"No, I swear to you, as the Lord lives,
I'll say, "No, I will marry this woman
over and over again to have these two
daughters because I can't imagine life
without them. The only things I love on
earth more than me is my daughters." And
the one I love more than them is Jesus
as well as the Holy Mother. I love the
Holy Mother more than my daughters. I'm
not. And I've always tried to be honest.
So sorry now it came out. I said I
wasn't, but it came out. What do you
want me to do? I apologize. I was blame
it. But see, I guess it was God's will
for me to do it. So brethren, I
understand if you hate me and you want
to you want to stop. So I understand. I
swear to you, you don't need me. I'm not
being fake. You don't need me. The Lord
doesn't need me. We need the Lord.